president trump's supreme court nominee
is back on capitol hill this morning
after a full day of answering questions
yesterday members of the senate
judiciary committee questioned
judge amy coney barrett's stance on
issues like abortion rights and gay
marriage
barrett sidestepped those topics saying
she would not forecast her decisions
she promised the senator she's made no
commitments
it would not let her personal beliefs
get in the way of the law
judges can't just wake up one day and
say i have an agenda i like guns i hate
guns i like abortion
i hate abortion and walk in like a royal
queen and
impose you know their will on the world
let me be clear i have made no
commitment to anyone
not in this senate not over at the white
house about
how i would decide any case democrats
repeatedly asked barrett if she'd vote
to overturn the affordable care act and
in one exchange vice presidential
nominee kamala harris asked her about
obamacare subscribers who have
pre-existing conditions
what wait would you give the fact that
135 million americans with pre-existing
conditions are now depending on the
protections of the affordable care act
what would you give that
i can't really say sitting here how they
would play in a way in this case because
that's part of the legal calculus of the
case
judge barrett did say that people with
pre-existing conditions would be
considered
in the case that will be argued at the
supreme court next month
though she would not specify to what
extent cbs news chief legal
correspondent jan crawford joins us from
washington now jan good morning
judge barrett is certainly not the first
supreme court nominee to sidestep
where they stand on particular key
issues what was your takeaway
from the hearings well i mean that's
right i mean she stuck to that supreme
court script that goes back
40 years to when justice sandra day
o'connor was sitting in that chair no
hints
no forecast of how they might decide any
cases or issues that might come before
them but
i thought what was notable is that she
didn't shy away
from her personal views she was very
forthcoming that she is a
woman of deep faith a catholic she's
pro-life
but she stressed that those personal
views she's never imposed them on people
in her life and she wouldn't do that as
a justice
i don't remember seeing that before that
kind of forthcoming
not dancing around the issues of how she
thinks personally
does that give us any sense of what kind
of supreme court justice she might be
jen
it does in a way but not as much as what
also i thought was a big clue from these
hearings and this was also something
that was really different she flat out
said
look i see the law i would interpret the
law a lot like my old boss justice
antonin scalia
who of course was one of the most
conservative justices on the supreme
court
she emphasized that she wouldn't be
justice scalia that she would be
justice barrett and she pointed out that
even justice scalia and justice clarence
thomas
have disagreements but justice scalia
and justice thomas
are really conservative so most people
wouldn't see a lot of daylight between
there
that was really different and in some
ways that tees up what i think could be
almost an historic
first for this nomination she could be
the first
conservative woman with that strong
overarching judicial philosophy the
supreme court has ever had she's only
had one conservative woman justice
sandra day o'connor
but she was more of a pragmatist and she
voted with liberals
quite often certainly in the back half
of her career all right jan crawford
thanks so much for being with us this
morning